I think it's time I shared my own list
of off-limit foods hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
of the past few years here on YouTube
and Tick Tock I've seen a lot of
nutritionists post their lists of like
scary foods that they'll never eat or
List off a bunch of strict diet rules
that they live by and I've always kind
of been irked by the rigidity
fear-mongering and borderline disorderly
nature of these posts but I also fully
understand your curiosity here and I'm
sure a lot of you want to know about the
rules that I follow with my diet as well
especially because I'm kind of like an
anti-rule dietitian it's definitely
off-brand for me since I'm all about
rejecting diet mentality and that means
ignoring with Society or another
influencer suggests is the right way to
eat and yet when I really sat down to
think about it I realized yeah like I do
have a general way I like to eat but the
difference between my rules Now versus
my rules 17 years ago when I had an
active Ed is all about intention and
flexibility I spent the past two decades
healing my relationship with food and
with that has come a lot of data
collection on what feels good to my body
my intention is to fuel my body in a way
that serves me best so my rules today
serve me not someone else and let's be
real rules of super click baby word but
it's probably not the best word to
capture the flexibility in this diet
pattern as I realize that there are
always going to be exceptions to my
rules just because a way of eating
usually feels best doesn't mean that it
will always feel best in every situation
or that I always have to eat what I know
feels best there's always going to be
social eating events parties and they're
just also unique individual cravings and
I honor those unique experiences even if
I know I might not feel so great after
but generally speaking this is how I eat
as a dietitian mom role model someone
with Digest adjusted issues mental
health issues and reproductive issues
and someone who aims to eat intuitively
here are my diet rules and reminder this
is not a prescription on how to eat so
please do not follow my rules or
eliminate the foods that I reduce in my
diet these guidelines are the result of
years of individual data collection so
please speak to a dietitian to work
through your own body data all right
rule number one I don't drink juice I
mean unless there's a little bubbly in
there
but honestly I rarely buy or drink juice
juice was actually a big fear food for
me when I was struggling with food like
I condition myself not to drink my
calories no matter what and as a result
I really obsessed over juice and like
hyper sweet calorie dense drinks and I
would over consume them whenever I
allowed myself to cheat AKA binge but
when I started to give myself
unconditional permission to consume
juice I realized that it actually wasn't
really for me I find that it like coats
my mouth in a gross film that I don't
like it messes with my digestion a bit
and it usually just tastes too sweet for
me I also would just rather get my
fruits and vegetables with fiber now of
course there's always exceptions to this
rule uh sometimes I craved OJ when I was
pregnant so I'd have some then and
sometimes I crave it in the morning
after like a big heavy meal or if I
drink too much and in those cases I
drink juice but it's definitely not
something that I typically buy rule
number two I don't drink soda similar
story with soda and I've honestly tried
hard to test myself to see like is this
a lingering remnant of my past Ed but my
body just does not care for soda I also
don't drink diet soda so this is
definitely not like a calorie saving
thing uh but real soda again coats my
mouth in a gross film doesn't feel good
to my body or my sleep and diet soda
probably feels even worse I have nothing
against aspartame or artificial
sweeteners for the masses but I just
know that they do not feel good to my
gut and I also cannot stay on the
aftertaste I sometimes get this random
craving for like a really cold Coke or
Diet Coke but once I open the bottle or
the can and I get like one sip I'm like
nope not for me craving crushed I'm good
for another five months but when I was
struggling with my Ed I would drink two
to four cans of Diet Coke every single
day probably because I was trying to
suppress my appetite satisfy my desire
for sweetness and give myself some kind
of like energy from the caffeine so yeah
maybe this has some like PTSD elements
to it and that's why my preference is to
not have soda but either way it's
definitely enough for me dog number
three I don't consume Splenda or
aspartame now I've discussed the safety
on artificial sweeteners in the past and
I think they are fine and safe to
consume for most people but again I used
to be heavily reliant on them both from
the aspartame in the diet coke plus like
tons of Splenda that I put my coffee and
oatmeal every day when I actually gave
myself unconditional permission to eat
sugar and I kind of edged these
artificial sweeteners out of my diet my
taste buds actually started to change I
just didn't want things to be sickly
sweet anymore so even just a little bit
of aspartame or splenda tastes way too
aggressive for me I can't even have any
sweeteners in my coffee actually and I
also cannot tell you how much better I
felt without them so splenda for sure we
know is not sibo friendly and aspartame
it's debated but maybe because I was
consuming such large amounts of it via
Diet Coke just the sheer volume tipped
the scale and did not feel good also
about a year ago I realized that the
protein powder that I was regularly
consuming had Splenda and so I switched
to a Stevia or monk fruit based product
and I realized how much better my body
felt and the flexibility piece comes in
when like I'm offered something to try
or it's like a small portion I don't
obsess over it it's all good but I just
don't purposely make these sweeteners a
major part of my diet number four I
don't eat at chain fast food joints like
McDonald's
oh they toasted a good for me okay so
first of all this is definitely a
privilege thing more than a nutrition
thing like I literally have never had a
thought about McDonald's like oh that's
so unhealthy or oh that's so bad or such
junk I never think about the salt or the
fat or the sugar in these Foods I
honestly just don't really enjoy them I
live in a city that is full of really
delicious food options a lot of them
aren't necessarily even more expensive
or even more healthy than McDonald's
like I'll order fish and chips from a
greasy chip truck and basically drown it
in sugary ketchup like not a green thing
in sight before I go through a Wendy's
or McDonald's drive-through and honestly
I I know that meals like this like
devoid a fiber don't make me feel great
usually I feel a little sluggish after
and if it's dinner and I've got no fiber
especially if there's little booze
involved I will be constipated the next
day I know this and I'm going to talk
more about this in a minute so I
personally just do not feel like most
chain fast food is like worth [ __ ] up
my digestion for a day having said that
sometimes I crave like a McDonald's
McFlurry so I'll get that or if I repeat
in the boons without a lot of options I
would of course stop to have a meal but
it's just not something that I seek out
very often number five I pretty much
only drink on the weekend I mean if I'm
on holidays and like every day is the
weekend am I right but I do try to have
structure with my week specifically with
alcohol because I know that alcohol
doesn't add anything nourishing to my
body like food does even if I were to
compare that with high calorie less
healthy food so unlike with most foods
that I don't put limitations on I do try
to limit my consumption of alcohol to
weekends and never more than like two
times a week now here's the honest truth
I like an adult Bevy sometimes I like
too so I need to balance my own fun and
pleasure with the responsible part of my
brain that has to deal with the reality
of being a 35 year old mom and business
owner
I know that alcohol does not make my
body feel good it dehydrates me so
pretty much without fail I will be
constipated the next day even if I try
to up my water and it also really messes
up my sleep and my blood sugars in the
night so if I choose to drink I am
knowingly choosing a bad night's sleep
and like a frustrating morning just
trying to get myself to poop so out of
respect for my own aging body I try to
really only drink on the weekends when I
know I've got more flexibility in the
day that follows to just like make it
through so usually that's once Max twice
a week if I were to break my rule and
like drink on a Wednesday I wouldn't
punish myself like I used to when I had
an ed like this is not about saving
calories or trying to like burn off that
cocktail at the gym this is about
limiting the self-punishment of a
hangover in my Elder Millennial age rule
number six I eat protein and produce at
almost every meal and this is one of
those rules that I literally really do
not even think about I just intuitively
know that this is how I build a meal
protein keeps me satrated so that I can
get to that next meal without needing to
have a snack and I know that that's
important to me personally because
spacing out my meals has really helped
with my digestion and sibo prevention by
stimulating the migratory Motor complex
and then produce whether it's veggies or
fruit definitely helps me to feel
hydrated and gives me that fiber that I
need to stay regular once or twice a
week I will like eat out and have just
straight up carbs like pasta or pizza or
both maybe even dessert but again I
always know that this is probably going
to back me up the next day so it's not
something that I purposely do very often
rule number seven I don't skip meals
like never pretty much never like maybe
if I were to be very sick but even then
I would probably try to find something
easy on my tummy to get that fuel and
yes this may seem counter to intuitive
eating and it often feels like it is but
you have to remember that intuitive
eating is not just the hunger fullness
diet it's about self-care and I know
that there are a lot of reasons why I
might not feel very hungry one day
sometimes I'm sad sometimes I'm stressed
or tired or wired or I feel nauseous
because I have coveted or whatever or
something else I ate but I know that my
body still needs fuel and if I skip a
meal it usually catches up to me and
causes like a ripple effect of problems
after but if I were to skip dinner I'd
wake up in the night hungry which
disrupts my sleep and then I start to
have anxiety about not sleeping from
Hunger which exacerbates my insomnia for
days weeks to come meanwhile I get a
headache in the morning for under
fueling and my digestion the next day is
all thrown off because I had to eat
something in the middle of the night so
skipping one meal because I just didn't
feel like eating could potentially take
me days to recover from just due to some
of the other physical and mental health
issues that I have so again I know my
body I know that it needs consistent
fuel to operate at its best so out of an
active self-care knowing that I usually
actually feel better when I do eat
something I pretty much never skip a
meal and speaking of not skipping a meal
I also never skip my bedtime snack
honestly I just don't feel emotionally
satisfied without a snack before bed and
I also know that I likely won't make it
through the night without that last
post-dinner Nosh I was raised in a
bedtime snack on a family so this may be
partially habitual but growing up we
always had peanut butter on those like
simple little kind of basic crackers or
buttered French toast every night before
bed like it's actually one of my most
Vivid childhood memories like I can
smell and I can taste that toast right
now and today my kids have a bedtime
snack every night and I still cannot
like cannot go to bed without one myself
it's actually not that different from
the whole like I need something sweet
after a meal thing even if I feel
satiated I still want to have a bedtime
snack so this is basically what we call
mouth hunger so the need to eat for a
specific flavor or sensation rather than
the need to eat for like a physical
hunger and mouth hunger is a total
totally valid reason to eat judgment
free for me the Bedtime snack is a
combination of mouth hunger and
preventing physical stomach hunger in
the night to protect and preserve my
delicate sleep so yeah leave me a
comment below if you are also a bedtime
snacker rule number nine I move my body
every day pretty much every day even on
Christmas unless again I'm feeling sick
now that doesn't mean I do a formal
workout every day I don't obsessively
exercise every day but unless I'm really
sick and it will not feel good to me I
do move my body every day and this is
more for my mental health and my
physical health it's definitely not to
maintain or change my body weight but
regular movement also feels pretty much
Essential for my digestion and
regularity as well and if you want to
see what kind of movement I generally
get up to in my usual work week you can
check out my video right here but even
if I were to be stuck on like an
airplane or in a car I would try to get
up like stretch my legs stimulate like
my muscles a little bit because I just
know that when I don't everything just
slows down not good and Rule Number 10 I
keep unhealthy Foods in my house always
no exception doesn't matter where we are
a bag of chips or a carton of ice cream
is never too far away the years when I
didn't keep these kinds of foods in my
house were really the years when I
binged hard whenever I got the chance if
anyone's seen the classic binge scenes
in the show physical with Rose Burns you
know what I'm talking about now if
keeping bad foods out of your house
helps you in your Wellness Journey
personally then cool you do you but this
is an actual hard rule for me seeing
those foods every time I open the
freezer or the pantry has helped to
neutralize their power it's made them
just another food so it doesn't matter
if we're traveling or we're staying in
the cottage or Airbnb or here at home
I'm pretty much always fully stocked so
I hope that was helpful for you guys you
know some of you who maybe don't know me
very well were possibly expecting me to
say that like I never eat canola oil or
like a Subway sandwich or chemical Laden
Cool Whip but like that I'm a 90s kid
Cool Whip slaps am I right you can't
have a pie without Cool Whip Cool Whip
Cool Whip yeah these are the most honest
and closest things to rules that I have
in my food books and they're honestly
just so innate at this point it's just
kind of what I do because it's what
feels best to my body and my mind so I
would love to hear what some of your
personal food rules are that you employ
because it makes your body feel its best
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with what you'd
like to see me talk about next subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye foreign
[Music]